foreign
[Music]
managing insects can be a quite a tricky
business
40 kilometers outside of Vienna at the
international atomic energy agency's
Laboratories
scientists from more than two dozen
countries work at this lab experimenting
with radiation is a tool for change
their Innovations can help farmers save
billions of dollars by eradicating pests
and creating higher yielding crop
varieties historically how we would
manage our insect base with with the
spraying of insecticides so using a
sterile insect technique can
dramatically reduce the amount of the
signal size needed to control or
maintain these insect nests now business
is booming for the lab because of
climate change millions of dollars are
pouring into the lab to expand its Putin
bug production as countries ask for more
help to adapt to life on a warming
planet
by exposing seeds and insects to
controlled doses of radioactivity these
scientists try to accelerate natural
evolutionary processes and select for
desired traits for bugs like TT flies
and mosquitoes that means males that
can't procreate for probs like bananas
and rice mutations might help farmers
adapt to more arid conditions or
increase yields we would sterilize the
males using radiation either gamma rays
or x-rays this will then make a small
change to the DNA structure mainly
within this firm of the insects then we
will release them in in the wild and the
males will look for the females made
with them and the females will not be
able to produce any Offspring so we use
birth control against the insects
themselves
climate change has exponentially boosted
demand for the lab services that's
because warmer weather allows
disease-carrying insects to travel
further and reduces the yields of crops
that have been adapted to hotter
temperatures
countries are investing more than 50
million dollars into cyber store for
expanding lab capacity and drawing a
steady stream of senior government
officials reviewing its work
and then there's the emerging mutant
seed space race
radiation
as microgravity and has extra
extra and we actually placed seeds
inside the International Space Station
we also placed seeds outside the
International Space Station so the hope
is that this kind of exposure is going
to trigger some genetic changes in the
seeds that would allow us to bring the
seeds back and select form extreme harsh
conditions for growth on Earth under
this climate change scenario that we are
finding challenging
unlike past experiments focused on
growing food for astronauts this one
hopes to bring home new mutations that
can thrive on Earth they'll undergo
studies and field trials when they land
back at the iaea in April I think that
insects are fantastic animals and yes we
we always have to live with them and
it's very difficult to manage them but
it's important that we use the correct
tools and I think it's our
responsibility to try to manage these
problems that we have for the
environment in a respectable way
foreign